en este vídeo veremos antibióticos
betalactámicos tras la cta más son
técnicamente amigas sin embargo son
diferentes de amigas típicas primero que
nada veamos una amiga típica sabemos que
el par libre de electrones no está
localizado en el nitrógeno está
deslocalizado participa en la resonancia
cuando dibujamos la estructura resonante
para una amiga
este oxígeno de arriba obtiene una carga
formal de menos 1 y habrá un doble
enlace entre el carbono y el nitrógeno
así que déjame continuar dibujando
nuestros grupos r eso le dará al
nitrógeno una carga formal de más 1
y si vemos la estructura resonante en la
derecha y si pensamos en el estado de
hibridación del nitrógeno en esta
estructura resonante obviamente tiene
hibridación sp2 indicando que el
nitrógeno
la nada
en una vida ideal el nitrógeno planar da
el mejor tras la peor vitales y eso
permite a este par libre de electrones
estar deslocalizado lo que incrementa la
densidad electrónica alrededor del
carbono carbónico y entonces esto hace a
nuestro carbono carbónico menos electro
físico y por ende menos reactivo
y entonces esa es la razón por la cual
las amigas generalmente no son reactivas
esta es una amiga ideal hay una especial
en la penicilina una vida en un anillo
la cual llamamos la cta ma veamos la
estructura general para la penicilina
aquí o para un derivado de la penicilina
porque puedes cambiar el derivado
cambiando el grupo r lo que puedes
cambiar a amoxicilina por ejemplo
buscamos nuestro anillo la cama es una
vida en un anillo y puedes ver que aquí
está nuestra la cama si quisieras
clasificar esta la cama el carbono junto
a este carbón y lo es el carbono alfa y
el carbono de junto es el carbono beta y
luego tenemos al nitrógeno y es por eso
que lo llamamos anillo d
durante la segunda guerra mundial hubo
un gran esfuerzo para sintetizar
penicilina los químicos no sabían la
estructura exacta pero obviamente si
lograban hacerla hubiera sido una gran
ayuda en el esfuerzo de la guerra se
sabía que la penicilina era hidrolizada
fácilmente en ácido o en base algunos
químicos creyeron que un anillo
lactámicos no podría estar presente
porque hay resonancias tan fuertes en la
vidas que debían de reducir la
reactividad
no debería de ser tan sencillo y
realizarlas sin embargo otros químicos
como r&b woodward favorecía la
estructura de tal acta mica y por
supuesto esos químicos probaron estar
correctos y woodward creyó que este
arreglo interesante de estos dos anillos
en la penicilina déjame mostrarte estos
dos anillos de aquí tenemos un anillo de
cuatro miembros el cual es una veta la
cama y luego tenemos si piensas en este
anillo que está separado a la derecha
este anillo de cinco miembros es una
fusión de un sistema de cuatro y cinco
anillos y si ver la estructura del
modelo
debería decir que le tomé esta foto aquí
en la izquierda puedes ver que este
sistema ha funcionado de cuatro y cinco
anillos previene que el nitrógeno sea
plano déjame continuar y resaltar
algunos de estos átomos aquí este átomo
en azul es el nitrógeno y luego podemos
ver que hay carbón y los aquí en la
izquierda y luego hay un sistema
fusionado de cuatro y cinco anillos y
pensando en este nitrógeno viendo esta
geometría de aquí vemos que este enlace
va hacia arriba y este enlace también va
hacia arriba un poco y entonces esto
definitivamente no es un nitrógeno plano
y ya que no es plano no obtendrás el
mismo tipo de estabilización en la
resonancia del que hablamos por aquí
el nitrógeno no puede donar tanta
velocidad electrónica a nuestro carbono
carbónico debido a este sistema
fusionado de 4 y 5 anillos los orbitales
no se traslapan lo suficiente que ya que
no hay tanta donación electrónica a
nuestro carbono carbón el ico esto hará
a este carbono carbónico más
parcialmente positivo más electro físico
y por ende más reactivo esa es una de
las razones por las cuales esta beta
lactamasa resulta ser hidrolizada
fácilmente otra razón por la cual esta
beta lactamasa puede romperse es debido
a la atención de anillo o tensión
angular veamos nuevamente este sistema
funcionado de anillos a déjame continuar
usando negro para que sepamos de qué
estamos hablando aquí aquí está nuestra
veta la cama sólo la dibujaré aquí para
que puedas ver
y otro gen o ahí el azul un anillo de
cuatro miembros y si pensamos en el
estado de hibridación de este carbono de
aquí este carbono está unido a cuatro
átomos tiene hibridación sp3 el ángulo y
vial de enlace para un carbono con
hibridación sp3 es de 109.5 grados
ese es el
d
y podemos ver que estamos lejos del
ideal en esta situación y no sé
exactamente cuál será pero
definitivamente es menor que 109.5 así
que si piensas en este como un cuadrado
podría estar más cercano a 90 grados un
valor por ahí un ángulo de enlace
cercano a 90 grados un valor cercano
estoy segura de que no es de 90 grados
exactamente es una desviación del ángulo
de enlace ideal de ciento 9.5 grados y
entre más se desvíe de 109.5 habrá más
tensión por lo que llamamos a esto
tensión de anillo o tensión angular y
cuando estás haciendo un modelo puedes
de hecho sentir a estos enlaces como
doblados y esto solo te da una idea de
la tensión que está presente haciendo
estos modelos puedes de hecho sentir
esta tensión angular y la mejor manera
de aliviar esa tensión angular sería
rompiendo
puedes realizar tu amiga puede romper el
anillo de aquí y puedes ver que eso es
lo que estoy dibujando aquí en la
derecha
'hemos hidrolizado está a mida hemos
aliviado esa atención angular viendo el
ángulo ahora este ángulo se ha
incrementado ya no está alrededor del 90
definitivamente ha incrementado
se está acercando a nuestro ángulo de
enlace ideal de 109.5 esa es la idea de
tensión angular obtención de anillo
abrir el anillo alivia esa función y
lleva a tu ángulo de enlace más cerca al
valor ideal si estás pensando por
ejemplo en este carbono teniendo una
hibridación sp3 tenemos estos dos
factores que hacen al anillo beta
lactámicos muy reactivo uno es que no
hay tanta estabilidad por resonancia y
el otro es tensión de anillo y entonces
estas dos cosas combinadas hacen esto
extremadamente reactivo bien veamos el
mecanismo de acción de la penicilina
aquí tenemos nuestro derivado de la
penicilina y por aquí abajo tenemos la
enzima trans peptidasa la cual es una
enzima de bacterias que se usa para
construir las paredes celulares de esas
bacterias y entonces esta de aquí es la
enzima
y da
y podemos ver que la enzima activa tiene
un bache en ella
y este o h funcionará como núcleo filo y
atacar a nuestro carbón o carbón y lico
aquí en nuestro anillo beta lactámicos
sabemos que este carbono carbónico es
más electro físico que en la mayoría de
las amigas y también sabemos que hay
tensiones de anillo o de ángulos
significantes y esa es de hecho la
porción reactiva de nuestra molécula
derivada de la penicilina y entonces el
núcleo fi lo ataca al electro filo el
núcleo fi lo ataca el electro filo y
estos electrones se van al oxígeno y
luego cuando vuelves a formar el carbón
y lo esos electrones regresan para
volver a formar al carbón y no lo que
mandará a estos electrones al nitrógeno
y entonces esto es básicamente un
mecanismo de sustitución a cilic a
núcleo física y entonces vamos a romper
a la medida y continuamos mostrando el
producto aquí
qué es lo que pasaría bueno déjame
resaltar algunos de estos átomos para
que podamos seguirlos este oxígeno de
aquí es este oxígeno y este carbono de
aquí es este carbono de aquí y entonces
rompimos el enlace rompimos el enlace
entre el carbono y el nitrógeno y ese
sería este micro gen o de actos déjame
continuar circulando lo y este nitrógeno
tomo un protón en el proceso y el puesto
ahora es que ahora podemos deshabilitar
la enzima
esta es ahora una enzima deshabilitada
ya no está esté o h libre aquí si está
deshabilitada no puede construir paredes
celulares para la bacteria y si la
bacteria no puede construir paredes
celulares
eso significa que nuestro sistema
inmunológico puede pelear contra
cualquier infección bacteriana que no
tenga paredes celulares y esta es la
idea de cómo los antibióticos de está
lactámicos como la penicilina funciona
previenen que las bacterias construyan
paredes celulares y luego nuestro
sistema inmunológico puede hacer el
resto todo viene de pensar en la química
de este anillo beta lactámicos